Listening to radio lab radio
from W N y. S. E n.
N. P. R. Ladies and Gentlemen,
please welcome to the stage
your host for this evening.
Jad Abumrad and Robert Krulwich.
[inaudible].
Okay, so Robert and I have been
on tour for the last two months.
We went to city after city after city,
something like 21 cities. We went
to year. We were both like, yeah,
sick kicked their asses,
but it was so much fun and the show was
called apocalyptical is about endings,
which is not the most obvious topic
to choose to invite people to do with
theaters. Hey,
we're going to just tell you different
stories that end really brilliantly,
but these are, this is a
series of ending stories.
That's what we did that night and we
did it with some amazing musicians and
comedians and video artists who projecting
beautiful images on these massive
screens above our head and also we
had puppets, enormous, beautiful,
articulate, gorgeous puppets,
and you can see all this.
We are releasing a really nicely shot
video of this entire performance at the
same time as this audio podcast.
Go to radiolab.org/live you
can watch the whole thing.
He knows some of the best moments
of the show were purely visual,
so we'd encourage you to check it out.
But what follows is the audio
podcast version of that show,
which we recorded live at the paramount
in Seattle. This show actually
truly begins with a radical rethinking
of one of the most important ending
stories that has ever
happened on planet earth,
which is the story about
the end of the dinosaur.
There's all kinds of, uh,
dinosaur puppetry, beautiful
stuff at the beginning,
uh, which we're going to skip over.
But again, you can check it out at
radiolab.org/live we're going to jump to
the part where we hear from scientists
who had been forensically probing this
moment and have a totally new way of
thinking about it. Okay, we're going
to start you off with a guy. Well,
the guy who started it off for us,
it's a guy named Jay Jay Malosh
professor at Purdue University,
and I study impact craters
among other things.
Not only can Jay Malosh create
impact craters with his mind,
but he and his colleagues have been
investigating this moment almost as if it
were a crime scene that happened not
60 million years ago, but yesterday.
And the story that they've put together,
it's more than just interesting.
It's frankly,
frankly terrifying and weirdly
specific as it happens.
Take for example the seemingly simple
question of when, when did it happen?
You don't mean like the year, cause
that would be a little too specific. No,
I don't know if you remember what Jay,
you got even more specific than that.
This was a casual question that I
threw out. Listen to his answer. By
the way, do we know anything
about seasons? Was this
hit at warm particularly?
Actually it was between, well
this is a bit of a stretch,
but it was some time between June
and July. Helium, you can say that.
And so specifically, how would you
know that the reasoning is we can,
for example, um, this was the
a, this was the first surprise.
Kind of a controversial idea, but
that basically goes like this. J says,
scientists have found
some pollen in rocks,
which date from that time to different
kinds of pollen and based on an analysis
of those two kinds of pollen,
we know that the um,
impact took place between the flowering
of the Lotus and the flowering of the
water and only [inaudible]. Okay,
so that's what Lotus you see
flowering on the left gets a water,
the leaf flowering on the
right, you can see this.
If you look at our video online fossils
found at the impact site that had pollen
from both of these
flowers in the same rock,
which suggest that the impact did in fact
take place somewhere between June and
July. It's one of those
things in geometry, we,
we get a glimpse of a a
moment far, far back in time.
So let's go deeper into that moment.
[inaudible]
all right, everybody, let's collectively
rewind our minds back in time.
10 millions of years into the past
66 million years ago to be precise.
There they are, majestic beasts
hanging out on the plains,
eating their lotus leaves
sometime in June,
June 17th let's say,
and everything on this day.
Pretty much normal.
This particular fateful day
was no different than any
of millions and millions
of previous days as far as
the dinosaurs were concerned,
but if there were any strong numbers
at the time, which they weren't,
they might have had some inkling that
something was coming because they looked
up. They would have seen
tiny
no dot have lightened
the sky wars planets,
the moon move with respect to the stars.
This would have had a constant bearing
and the old semen could tell you that if
you see something constant bearing
that's on a collision course with you and
that thing of course is are
asteroid zeroing in on the earth.
I want to say that we do know quite a
bit about this asteroid from the size of
the creator and from the amount of
certain minerals found at the impact site.
We know that the asteroid was roughly
six miles wide and then again roughly six
miles long,
which makes it approximately the size of
Manhattan island or our Mount Everest.
It's roughly the size of Mount
Everest. That is Doug Robertson,
a geologist who knows quite a bit about
this asteroid and by the way it has a
and that it's, it's the
asteroids called Baptist
Stena Baptist Dema y that
Stena Baptist in, I dunno,
update the name asteroids
on another subject.
We do know that the Earth's moon was
probably produced by a collision with
something the size of Mars.
Well I just threw that in cause it's
cool. It doesn't really relate to us.
Sorry, we don't have the whole evening
here. Let's just stay to it. Okay.
The dinosaurs are here on earth. They
are eating near leaves. Meanwhile,
up in space, our asteroid Baptist Dina
is now hurtling towards the earth,
20,000 miles an hour area fast 20 times
faster than a very fast rifle moment and
scientists couldn't be sure what
would happen mathematically.
I mean when in a Mount Everest size
bullet traveling at 20,000 miles an hour,
it's our atmosphere. The
atmosphere is really just a very,
very thin skin over the rest of the earth.
So scientists that, all right, if
we're going to construct this story,
let's just take it piece by piece and
first figure out what would happen when
this big ball hurling through
space slams into our atmosphere,
which is made of gas of course.
So just to approximately,
let's fire a bullet through some gas
and watch what happens.
Now here we basically showed a super slow
motion video of a gun firing a bullet
underwater. You can see it on our
website, radiolab.org it's very beautiful.
You see the bullet coming out and
freeze it right there at the edge. Okay.
Basically what you see is this
bullet steaming through the water.
And by the way, we use water
as an approximation for gas.
Cause in gas you'd have this same effect
I'm about to describe creating a wake
behind it and the week gets wider and
wider as it trails away from the bullet.
And if you imagine this
shape in three dimensions,
really what you're looking at is a
kind of a cone, like a funnel shape.
And inside the the, the, that,
the wallets of the funnel
inside that cone is nothing,
nothing, nothing. Because it's in water.
So you're saying there's, there's,
it's like a hole in the water. That's
what I'm saying. There's nothing in there.
It's a vacuum in there because the,
the bullet is sh is
shooting through the water.
It pushes the water out
of the way and for a beat,
the water doesn't have time to come
back together and so all you have is
emptiness in there. Right there. This,
what you're seeing is a massive hole
in the water created by a tiny little
bullet.
Now imagine that that bullet is six miles
wide and the hole that it's making is
right above your head.
Well, what does that mean?
If you're a dinosaur looking
up would, what would happen?
Well,
if you were in the right place and this
is going to be the wrong place in the
secondary to you, we're
in the right place to,
to look behind the asteroid as it came in.
You'd probably be able to, to
see clearly through the space
[inaudible]
what does that mean?
You would suddenly be looking
at a nighttime hole in a
daytime sky. Right. Whoa.
To be fair, Jay did tell us that, uh,
you would need special kinds of
eyeballs to see this knight hole
in the day sky and the
Dinah's didn't have that.
So science still,
I mean just imagine what a last image
that would be to see day and night come
together in the same moment.
But according to Jay,
you better not blink because before
you could open your eyes again
[inaudible]
the asteroid would have hit the surface.
And if you are in a position to see that,
then you're going to be in Gulf by the
violence that is just about to occur.
By the way,
the audience was just laughing at a dinos
de Los Muertos graphic that just came
on the screens. So we know it was a big
explosion, fine, and it was violent,
fine.
But I think we should be a little bit
subtle about this because obviously if an
asteroid is the size of Manhattan
and it lands on your head,
you're not going to feel very good
about that. But if Manhattan is,
is hitting the planet earth,
that's a little bit like a pebble
hitting an enormous beach ball. Yeah,
and I can imagine that the,
the little pebble size relativistically
speaking the pebble would create some
damage in the spot where it landed.
But let's suppose that you are um,
alleviating mother of three Hadrosaur
living in New Zealand. Right?
And you're just spent at the
moment that the asteroid comes in,
you're on your Antipolo going
the other side of the planet.
Would you have any idea
that this was happening?
That was the next question
that we talked to Jay.
How much damage would this thing
actually do? Well, we can do experiments.
We can produce things,
situations like this in small
quantities in the laboratories gay.
Y'All send in here, which
brings us, we're good to hear.
You're good to this guy.
Peter Schultes and I like
to do impact experiments.
Pete Schultz basically has
every 13 year olds dream job.
He gets to blow shit up for living.
Basically what B does is he works at this
place that you're seeing right here on
the screen. This is the NASA Ames
laboratory in California. And uh,
the thing that they're putting together,
they're in the middle of frame.
That is a giant three story tall canon.
What beat does is he takes
projectile. So for example,
you're going to see him take a little
glass bullet over there and he's going to
load it into the top of the cannon and
then he's going to fire it right into a
standup for planet earth, which
for him will be a sand pit.
And lucky for us when we called Pete,
he was just about to pull
the trigger on this thing.
So you're are calling you on a day in
which you are trying to IX re-experience
the day. I actually, yeah, but I think
for him to survive, that's our plan
it in recent. Okay. Hold on.
We've got to assume the position.
Okay. We have to cross our fingers.
Okay, here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
We have all, I'm already like,
here we go.
Rolling.
Um,
that is gorgeous. Oh my
gosh. Are They gonna?
Is that get instant
playback thing. Oh my gosh.
That is the sound of a man.
Very happy with his explosion.
Yeah.
You can see every piece of
this, of what's happening.
So based on experiments like this,
people like p can figure out precisely
what happened when the asteroid hit the
earth.
They can quantify the explosions power
by basically leveraging up experiments
like this. So according to Doug,
the amount of energy that would have been
on leash when that thing came rushing
in onto earth
is roughly this.
Oh, we hit the earth with an explosion
that's 100 million mega ton. Yeah.
And [inaudible]. Okay,
Sara Lips Date Sarah, our guitars
Kinda swung her guitar around,
had a metal moment. Don't look
at her wrong or she'll do that.
Okay. So here's essentially how
Doug broke that down for us.
Two tons of tea and tea. We're
talking tons of, you're not mega tons.
Two tons of T. And. T.
We'll essentially do this.
Okay.
On one of the three screens, you
see a 10 story building imploding,
two tons of t and t will take down
a building. Now 15,000 tons of TNT.
That is what the United States dropped
on Hiroshima in 1945 on a second screen,
we see archival footage
of the atomic bomb.
That chaos has 15,000 tons of TNT. Now
these days, according to Doug Robertson,
a hydrogen bomb current hydrogen bombs
are typically of the order of 1 million
tons of TNT equivalent.
Now 1 million tons of TNT equivalent.
That's what we call a mega ton.
If you remember,
Doug said that the asteroid impact was
the equivalent of 100 million mega tons,
so really what he's saying in concrete
terms is that that impact was the
equivalent of 100 million of those bombs
going off all at once in the same spot,
which is a lot.
That is true. That is true.
However, it means it's,
it really depends on what you mean
by a lot because I was doing a little
googling and I was surprised to learn that
110 million mega tons is not nearly
enough to destroy the planet,
to destroy the entire planet. You
would need, you ready for this?
110 quadrillion mega tons of GT,
which is 100 million times 110
million mega tens of t. And. T.
So going back to your head resource
situation, mother of three in New Zealand,
if the thing came in Auntie portal to her,
maybe she would feel
the shake a little bit,
but after a minute she'd be like whatever.
And she'd go back to eating leaves.
You probably wouldn't notice it.
Well, no, no, no.
Cause that's not what we were taught in
homeroom by Mrs McGrew or whoever your
teacher was. Here's the
classic explanation. There
was an impact of course,
and it kicked up an enormous amount
of dust. You'll remember this.
The Dustin kind of covers the
planet. It blankets the earth,
makes the earth very cold, makes the
earth very nasty. All the big plants die.
The little plants get sick, the dinosaurs
get hungry, the dinosaurs get sick.
And then gradually, you know,
they get dead deader and deader and deader
from different things. 10,000 years,
30,000 years, four to
till you get like, oh,
like 900,000 years later
you've got a shivering.
Last dinosaurs sitting
there in the cold cold,
and that's the end. That's the
story we were told in school
is a long, slow wintery
collapse. Yeah, no, no.
Why we tell these good people that tired
old story from Mrs. What does it Miss?
Some recruiters make. I made her
Magruder tonight. Okay. Yeah.
Let us offer up a completely different
Tabish night, right? Scottish. All right,
we'll go with that. Let's actually
flip the understanding completely.
I think we should based on
new science, so all right,
here's what we're going to do. Keith,
pull up that a ballistics video that
we showed earlier with the red sand.
Can you sort of pull that up and blow it
up to the three screens and then, yeah,
rewind it back. If you just thank,
you wouldn't go back just a bit. Okay,
so this is a 6,000 frame.
A second video that you're
seeing here is from Pete's lab.
At this point on the screen, all you're
seeing is a pit of red sand. Now,
what you see in the first few frames is
you see the laser hitting right there,
red sand flying in the air, super
slow Mo. And the next frame forward,
right there, you see some fire,
you see a little bulb of fire
erupt near the impact site,
right where the laser hits the sand.
There's this little clump of
flame and we freeze on that spot.
Now scientists can now measure the
temperatures in that spot right there.
Oh yeah. Right there. Okay.
And just to state the obvious,
we know from those measurements that
that spot right there would have gotten
very, very, very,
very, very hot.
No, we beyond the temperature of the
sun, I mean we're talking temperatures,
maybe 20,000 degrees,
will sun's temperatures
about 5,000 degrees.
And if we're talking temperatures
four times hotter than the sun,
well anything that's that hot is going
to instantly, instantly turn to gas.
A very, very high temperature,
high pressure gas.
It's actually rock vapor rock esteem.
So imagine this thing comes
barreling in his asteroid.
It doesn't just bounce off the
earth. It plows into the earth.
It goes into the surface. Two miles
in, five miles in, seven miles in,
10 miles in 20 miles into the earth.
It goes all the rock that's it's plowing
into is turning into a liquid and then
into a gas and now
watch what happens next.
This is a basic physic experiment
we're going to show you on the screen.
You see it's very lovely video.
Actually have a hand dropping
a metal ball into some sand.
This is just a dude dropping a ball
and some sand. Watch this right here.
Paul goes in and like a
millisecond after it makes impact,
disappears into the sand.
A little spear of sand go shooting
back in the opposite direction.
Sort of a bounceback effect. Does this
always happen? This whatever this is,
it's like Newton's law of something. Yeah.
Newtons love sand hook say, yeah,
but what you see is you see this fine
plume of Samuel shooting back in the
opposite direction as a
sort of rebound right now.
Imagine that that ball is an
asteroid and that sand over there,
that's the planet earth to
Keith. Play that one more time.
You play the video again, but
this time as the ball drops,
it gradually morphs into
an astroid. [inaudible].
Yes,
thank you for the south where you would
get the same effect you would get the
[inaudible].
The simple point is just something we do.
You wonder how where we get all of our
sound design is out of that man's mouth.
That's where you would
get that same bounce back
effective of fine blue shooting
back in the opposite direction, but
we know from what we just heard,
Doug described that it would
not be, would not be sand.
In this case it would be rocking gas. Yes,
we'll move hot gas expands upward and
pushes right on through the atmosphere up
into space.
Some fraction get the moon [inaudible]
some fraction of that hit Mars.
Okay, so now you've got this sneeze
of rock vapor. It's out in space.
Basic physics says that as it travels
out farther away from the earth,
what's going to happen is it's going
to start to cool down a bit and when it
cools, Yep.
Recondense is into little droplets that
a basically formed glass very quickly,
little droplets of glass
about the size of sand.
Now if you look at one of these little
droplets of glass under a microscope,
this is what it looks like
right there on the screen.
You see what looks kind of
like a translucent snowball.
That is actually an a magnified
image of one of these bits of glass.
It fell from space that day. Most
of them didn't land on the ground.
Talk about that in a second. There it is.
I don't know about you but I find
that totally terrifying cause that's,
it looks like a little Baptist
Dino, right? Tiny last joy. It's up.
Now imagine trillions of these things
in a cloud and a cloud of shrapnel going
out out,
away from the earth and what's going to
happen next is that it's going to start
to lose momentum. That cloud,
when it does the earth's
gravity is going to grab back,
hold it and say come on back. And
90% of them come back to the earth.
Well
does falling glass do harm? Yes.
Because what happens is that the,
the glass out in space starts to spread
out like north and south and east and
west and eventually it
will appear in the sky over
New Zealand. It's now a global
phenomenon and you know,
it's really hard to imagine what
the Hadrosaur would've seen.
But the thing to keep in mind is that
these things, as they're coming in,
these bits of glass, a 90 some odd
percent are burning up in the atmosphere.
So very few of them are hitting the
ground. So from her point of view,
probably would have looked
like the greatest media
shower any one has ever seen
with one significant
bummer, which is this,
when these little bits of glass come in,
each one that burns up is the positing
a little bit of heat into the sky.
And collectively there's such a
massive rain of these things coming in.
Well, the heat would build
up, the sky would turn red,
that would be getting hotter and hotter.
[inaudible]
and at a certain point,
Jay wondered, well,
how hard exactly would it have gotten the
how much heat exactly would have built
up there in the sky and then
started to radiate down.
Um, we, uh, calculated the amount
of heat that would come down, uh,
number 10 kilowatts per square meter
and yeah. Okay, well we get this number.
Well, what, what does that mean?
Well, I went home and I, um,
hooked up a, uh, uh,
current meter and pride to measure the
amount of heat produced in my oven for
different amounts of power.
And I could get about seven kilowatts
per square meter in my oven on broil.
Oh, like 500 degrees broil you
mean? But that wasn't quite enough.
Not nearly. So Jay started
measuring other kinds of ovens
and then I finally found out
that the heat would be in fact,
like being in a pizza oven,
a pizza oven is about right.
Which means that if you were addressed
real dinosaur anywhere above the ground
on the earth on that day, you
would have experienced some heat.
It is almost unimaginable.
Maybe it started at a hundred degrees
because it was June, it was summer,
but within minutes it would
have been 300 degrees,
500 degrees, 700 degrees,
900 degrees.
Estimates are on that day.
Temperatures topped out at
something like 1200 degrees
at that temperature. Nothing
can protect you, your scales,
your for whatever you got,
it's not going to do any good.
Your blood will literally start to
boil inside your body and you will die.
[inaudible]
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible]
[inaudible]
so essentially according to this theory,
the dinosaurs and everything else on earth
that day would have been incinerated.
Doug thinks that's what the
domain, not so much the impact,
but all that objective,
it went up into the sky,
came down as glass rain and created
that heat. That's what did the men,
he would argue it didn't just do some
of the men or even many of them in.
He would say it did all
of them in all at once.
There is zero evidence that
any dinosaur made it through.
And the crazy part of this theory is
that Jay and Doug thinks that the whole
process from the impact of the glass
rain to the incineration of all of these
species on the planet, it
would have taken a few hours.
His best guess, he thinks maybe two hours.
I mean, that's less time
than a a business lunch.
Yeah.
You try getting east northwest anywhere
on Mercer Street at rush hour in too,
and do that. I mean,
if you think about it,
that is less time than you will
spend in this theater tonight.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
that means that you're saying that
an animal that had been supreme
on the planet for 200 million
disappears in a few
hours. Completely. Yes.
Yup. That's
what the evidence suggests. That's right.
[inaudible]
well, you can consider the evidence, but
also you could consider common sense.
I mean, we've got a world filled
with terrestrial dinosaurs.
They were on every continent.
They were even in Antarctica.
And to say that they all
disappeared in two hours.
I mean all that would,
that suggests that there's
none of them out of harm's way.
None of them, many caves somewhere.
None of them in the
grotto, none of them in a,
in a protected forest of any kind.
The word all in that connection,
it's just too much a, I
just don't buy it. But yeah,
I mean the truth is that the science is
never going to be so exact as to say.
Yeah, all of them disappeared
or it happened on a single
day or on an afternoon.
I mean now no tool that
we have is that precise,
but what Jay is saying is that
it happened fast, very fast.
Nothing made it through.
What I find interesting is that ultimately
you don't need the ballistics or
anything.
We've shown you so far to
know that something major
and sudden happened because
you can see evidence of it
literally etched into the earth.
Here's the thought where we
first found within the boundary,
you can see it really well
out in Colorado actually.
We sent one of our producers,
Molly Webster out there to meet a
paleontologist named Kirk Johnson.
They hiked over a couple of hills.
They found this one specific spot,
Mike ready for a dinosaur to come around
the corner and the minute they started
to dig,
taking down like a foot
from where we were.
Turns out for every three feet you
get down 10,000 years in time. See,
the earth has layers,
kind of like a tree has rings
and every three feet down you go.
You're going back in time about 10,000
years and when you go all the way down,
all the way back to 66.0 9 million years,
you will find this one
little skinny strip of rock.
Okay?
That's the kiddie boundary that
this one skinny gray line,
this, this gray, crappy,
this. No, in a very real way,
that line that you're seeing
that represents the day
the asteroid hit the day
just above that line. That's
a little bit after the day.
Just below that line was
a little bit before today.
The line is called the KT boundary.
And what's cool is you
can actually touch it.
You can touch evidence of that
moment. And in fact, Kirk,
what he did that day was he
took his finger and he dug
a piece out and he handed
it to Molly.
We're hold, I'm holding.
You're holding the shake.
It's like a, it's almost
like chunks of coal. Yeah,
but it's not what you're holding.
Dark Gray mudstone the
carbon rich bud stone.
And in that mudstone you'll find
all kinds of things. I mean,
you'll find very rare minerals
like iridium that probably
came in on the astroid
and got smooshed into that line.
Those little glass balls I was talking
about this a little hell balls. Well,
if you get out a microscope
and you look at that rock,
you will see them in there. We put a funny
cartoon of the little hell
balls. They're all in that line.
How thick do you think that line is?
Which is about an inch
is like hidden in there.
It's sort of a story of that day.
Absolutely. And here's the crazy thing.
If this is the line right
here, this little strip here,
Robert traces a picture of the KT boundary
with his finger and then you dig just
below the line you were going to find
over and over again, dinosaurs everywhere.
I mean not going to be alive.
Of course he says putting
some toy dinosaurs under the
line and making them move
by giving them a certain amount
of energy, which I shouldn't,
but they are fossils and you will find
dinosaur fossils from Europe and Idaho
and Montana. This one
says it was made in China,
but if you just go above the
line, you don't find any done so,
so below the line,
scientists have looked everywhere
above the line and they haven't.
Well, everywhere they have looked
anyway, they found nothing, nothing,
nothing. It's a different world. That's
the amazing thing is a different world
and it's pretty rude, young.
This is one world. Nothing.
You're literally just pointing Pinky
to point. Your fingers spread. Yeah.
[inaudible]
this is another moment where I
would urge you at some point,
not now keep listening, but at some point
watch the video of this performance.
Cause what Sarah, Darren, Glen and
Keith do in this moment digitally.
It's pretty amazing.
A
[inaudible] [inaudible] eh,
a
[inaudible].
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
before we go to break,
I just want to give a very special
thanks to the people who shared the stage
with us. Sarah lip state from no velour.
Darren grey on the base in
Glen Coachee and the drums.
They're both from the band on Fillmore.
We were so lucky to share the stage
with those guys along with, um, uh,
video maestro key scratch
who was doing the live video.
[inaudible] brilliant puppet here,
Myron Guso. Oh my God. That guy.
So good. Check out all of them.
Radio lab.org/live. You can see
them doing what they do. Uh,
visually it's pretty, it's
pretty worth watching. Anyhow,
we'll be back in a second.